My parents are Haitian immigrants, they
came to the United States over 50 years
ago, my mother actually came to the US as
an au pair for a French American family
living the Boston suburbs, she eventually
moved to New York to join her mother and
her siblings; my father went directly to
New York and proceeded to earn an
engineering degree from the City College
of New York.
My mom eventually became a registered
nurse and when I went to college I went
with the expectation from my family that
I would pursue a major that's very
closely connected to the kinds of jobs
that existed in their universe so I was
either going to be an engineer or a
doctor or a lawyer; a lot of my
decision-making as an undergraduate was
really sharply structured around those
kinds of expectations, the idea of
eventually becoming an academic, it was
not even something that was in the range
of choices that were presented to me as
as possibilities. One of the ways in
which my experience as the daughter of
Haitian immigrants has influenced the
approach that I take to teaching and
mentoring is that I often work with
students who are either first generation
or also from immigrant families and they
come into college with clear
expectations about the choices they're
supposed to make. Part of my role as a
faculty member and as a mentor is to
respect the sort of the hopes and dreams
of many people often rests on the
shoulders of these students and that I'm
not only engaging with the student but
I'm probably engaging with the students
family; it's possible to pursue not only
educational choices that are legible to
your family and that provide a sense of
economic security but also to pursue
your intellectual passions; I think
bringing that kind of sensitivity to my
interactions with students that's something
that's so deeply influenced by my own
experience as the daughter of Haitian
immigrants.
One of my greatest passions
in my time in the role as dean of social
science for the last three years has
been nurturing what is the Inequality in
America Initiative and the initiative
itself in the first instance is
motivated just by the growing
recognition of the problem of inequality
and the broad impacts it has on
everything from individuals to families
to neighborhoods to entire societies so
there is a real-world urgency that
really calls for our engagement on this
issue, but is also the initiative has
been motivated by the sense that while
the study of inequality and teaching
about inequality has been really a core
strength for Harvard and for the FAS in
particular for some years that there's
actually a lot more that we could be
doing in this space; we actually joined
collaboratively and defined the study of
inequality as a collective enterprise
Over the last three years I've viewed my
my position as an opportunity to have
this this passport that allows me to go
and visit anthropology, attend seminars,
and understand what motivates and
excites anthropologists and then the
next day visit economics and attend a
job talk to learn what motivates and
excites economists and now with this
role it is as if I'm stepping from the
balcony to a rooftop view and really
being able to survey the full rich
diversity of the FAS and learn more not
only about what's happening in social
sciences but now also what excites
classicists in arts and humanities or to
learn more about engineering. I would
also say that one of the things that's
tremendously rewarding about being in
this kind of position is that you have
the opportunity to to shape and support
the faculty and so the opportunity to
bring to our campus the best minds
across a variety of fields and to help
set the conditions that allow them to do
their best work and I find that to be
incredibly rewarding